this right here is the hottest
Battleground for the future of
Automotive revenues the dashboard see
why you may only really use this screen
for music navigation and calls in the in
the future it's set to be used for a lot
more traditional automakers plan on
using this space to sell a suite of
features and services in a market that
some analysts estimate will be worth
some 1.5 trillion dollars by 2030 but at
the same time Tech giants like Apple and
Google are pushing to gain deeper
control of your vehicle and take over
more of your dash and now battle lines
are being drawn so who is winning the
battle of the dashboard let's find out
no please don't
quite enough of that now I know I've
said this before but if the car that
you're driving doesn't already receive
downloadable upgrades and updates over
the air then there's a strong chance
that the car that you buy in the future
will and that's because there's said to
be quite a lot of money in it or as
Tesla CEO Elon Musk said in an earnings
call we could sell for zero profit for
now and then yield actually tremendous
economics in the future through autonomy
GM is
next to generate between 20 to 25
billion dollars in revenue from software
enabled Services by 2030. stalantis has
forecast roughly 22.5 billion for the
same time and Accenture predicts that
Digital Services will make up a whopping
40 percent of Global Automotive revenues
by 2040. now that's crucial for these
automakers because right now they're
struggling to make money on EVS the
profit margin on these are much smaller
because the batteries are still
expensive and they haven't scaled yet
that's Mike Goliath who covers autos for
wsj for the next decade investors are
kind of wondering well how are you going
to bridge that short bar in the profit
margins that you're used to on your big
internal combustion the answer to an
auto executive is well we're gonna have
all this digital revenue and
subscription services so what do these
automakers plan on selling well at the
basic level they'll be the usual
offerings of music and entertainment as
well as navigation services to things
like parking spots valets EV charges and
gas stations then there's subscriptions
to physical in-car options that used to
be add-ons like heated seats more
horsepower or improved handling but one
of the most lucrative subscriptions is
said to be autonomous driving it may not
be here yet but that hasn't stopped some
automakers betting big on it or as musk
said we expect our vehicles over time
will be able to generate significant
profit through autonomy now some of
these upgrades are set to be accessed
through smartphones and computers but if
automakers are going to start selling
through the dash they're going to need
to get someone out the way first carplay
is the smarter safer way to use your
iPhone in the car chances are your car
is compatible with Android auto yep
Apple carplay and Android auto seat for
years automaker's own infotainment
systems lagged behind that of
smartphones mainly because cars operate
on longer product Cycles than
smartphones 10 plus years ago the car
companies I think thought they could do
this interface on their own they tried
the infotainment touch screens and the
cars weren't very good and so Apple and
Google came up with these solutions to
essentially mirror your your phone on
the touchscreen of the car a lot of
consumers now rely on this as their main
interface for the car now for a while
this partnership is working Dash screens
were pretty small and the smartphones
didn't really have much interaction with
the car itself but now those screens are
getting bigger we designed the new
Android auto UI to take advantage of
those larger screens and tech companies
are reaching deeper into the car there's
an opportunity for iPhone to play an
even more important role in 2022 Apple
announced that not only would carplay be
able to take over the whole dash
including the instrument cluster but
that the software would reach far deeper
under the hood tune your car's radio or
change your temperature without ever
leaving the carplay experience this is
just a taste of what the next generation
of carplay will bring that means that
Apple could potentially access some of
the very features that automakers are
trying to monetize and we all know how
good Apple and Google are at selling
downloads and subscriptions I mean
that's what Google app will do right I
mean they they offer you apps and and
features uh to pass your time so it's a
battle for that space I spoke to Apple
and Google but neither would tell me
about future Automotive plans but even
if Apple and Google don't monetize their
offerings their software still takes
over the dash
you've got a tech giant sitting in
between you and your customer it's going
to make it a lot harder to you know
monetize that stuff
so it may not be much of a surprise that
GM has stopped supporting Android auto
and apple carplay on future EV models I
know the GM considered letting carplay
live alongside of its new interface but
they ultimately felt like they were just
going to be fighting for eyeballs that
decision was met with immediate
criticism yeah I mean I heard from a lot
of people who said I'll never buy
another GM car again you know and I
think GM knows that and to that extent
it's a gamble so is this the beginning
of the end for carplay and Android auto
in cars well not exactly see even though
these software won't be supported in
future GM EVS the company still plans on
running its own infotainment system on a
version of Android's operating system so
Google will still be in the car and
despite GM's actions a few automakers
appear to be following suit for now at
least I I asked the number of Executives
from other companies almost all of them
said no way we have no plans to root
those from the Cars I think they see
that as potentially hurting sales but
that could all change see right now
Digital Services only make up around
five percent of Automotive revenues but
as that percentage starts to increase
don't be surprised if you see more
automakers start to unplug the
smartphone
[Music]